hey guys it is the 20th of May today my
name is Jess McCall and you're tuned
into games but news that fancy white
xbox one hailer bundle that Microsoft
gave us a peek at a while back is now on
its way to release in the US the console
comes with a copy of halo the master
chief collection the bundle is priced at
350 bucks and has already been available
in brazil since last year Microsoft's
have said that the bundle will be
offered in limited quantities and the
supply won't be replenished so when
they're gone you won't be able to pick
one up again if you do decide to get
yourself one it's worth knowing that the
game will come in the form of a digital
download code and not a physical disc
xboxes fell sponsor has said that while
Windows 10 is going to be arriving in
the summer the OS is integration into
the xbox one will come later
specifically Phil Spencer said it's
likely to launch quote post summer which
places its window at the beginning of
fall at the earliest Microsoft have
already confirmed that Windows 10
functionality will initially arrived on
Xbox one through their preview program
to enable feature testing windows 10 is
set to come to Xbox one via and update
although Spencer has promised that the
addition won't change the console into
an enterprise centric device finally
this year's needs the Speed game has
been teased by EA the publisher released
a teaser image of a fancy looking car
with the caption are you ready for the
next chapter sad fancy looking car also
features the word speedhunters on the
wheel that's the name of EA's car
culture community so the group might
have some role to play in the next title
although nothing is confirmed yet
current speculation suggests this could
be in you need for speed underground
game but the official announcement is
arriving tomorrow so you won't have to
wait long to find out one way or the
other let me know if you're keen foreign
you need to speed game and what you're
hoping to see EA announced tomorrow
you can have to gain spot we've got
stories on Nintendo hiring Bowser and
the new PS warm Morpheus to do that's
everything that I've got for you today
be sure to leave me your thoughts and
feelings in that comment section and
i'll catch you same time tomorrow